[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes de la tnt voici les titres de
l'actualité de cette édition tout
d'abord le bon début des vacances
d'hiver les touristes étrangers et
français sont au rendez vous après deux
années marquées par les restrictions
sanitaires un ouf de soulagement pour
les professionnels comme nous le
montrera la rédaction de votre
télévision bon pour l'environnement mais
pas forcément pour les affaires la
multiplication des zones à faibles
émissions dans les grandes villes
suscite inquiétude et colère de la part
de certains commerçants nous irons nous
en rendre compte à montpellier avec
vient occitanie sur place et si dormir
dehors en hiver était bon pour le
sommeil c'est l'expérience en tout cas
osé et réussi d'une crèche en bretagne
la sieste nordiques comme on la surnomme
permet au bébé de dormir plus longtemps
un reportage étonnant à découvrir avec
les chaînes de pébéo étaient des suds du
groupe le télégramme en bretagne devenir
célèbre et gagner de l'argent à tout
prix les vedettes le nouveau film du
palmashow est sorti dans les salles
mercredi la rédaction de tv 78 à
assister à l'avant-première avec les
deux humoristes dans les yvelines
certains d'entre vous en profite
peut-être déjà les vacances de février
vont s'étaler jusqu'en mars la zone b
avec le grand test a ouvert le bal
depuis une semaine dans la station de la
bresse dans les vosges les skieurs
étaient au rendez vous sur les pistes
une belle fréquentation et un indice de
confiance de bonne augure pour les
responsables de la station les vacances
de février représentent en moyenne 65 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires la préfecture
des vosges et ses partenaires ont
profité de cette affluence pour proposer
une journée découverte des beautés du
massif mais aussi de ses dangers avec
une démonstration des sapeurs pompiers
reportage de marie danielle hrgovic pour
votre télévision
c'est parti pour les vacances de février
qui vont durer un mois c'est la zone b
qui inclut le grand test qui ouvre le
bal et samedi dernier à la station de la
bresse hohneck trente et une piste sur
33 étaient ouvertes de quoi faire le
bonheur des skieurs pour une journée ou
plus c'est la première fois qu'on voyait
donc on venait ici et c'est cool est là
juste aujourd'hui entre amis pour fêter
un anniversaire voilà c'est on est
content
en tout cas cette première journée avait
des airs presque d'avant crise le
protocole sanitaire est en effet à des
jets plus d'obligations des masques en
extérieur à porter seulement sur les
remontées mécaniques
considérés comme des moyens de
transports publics
le pass vaccinale est requis pour y
accéder avec des contrôles aléatoires
pour les 12 15 ans et encore le pass and
i ter qui peut s'appliquer n'est pas de
quoi freiner la fréquentation les
vacances de février elle représente dans
cette station environ 65% du chiffre
d'affaires et les responsables sont
confiants sur cette première semaine
entre 6 ou 6 et 8000 skieurs et puis sur
la semaine prochaine on sera plutôt
entre huit et dix mille skieurs par jour
sur les vacances de février c'est ce
qu'on avait les années précédentes
samedi dernier c'était aussi l'occasion
pour la préfecture et ses partenaires
d'aller à la rencontre du public pour
une autre découverte de la montagne mais
aussi pour en connaître tous les risques
avec cette démonstration de secours en
cas d'avalanche on a une personne
ensevelie faucon latron
on est un massifs de moyenne montagne
mais le risque montagneux présent et du
coup c'est une journée de prévention
pour sensibiliser les gens à ces risques
là tout est dit pour profiter pleinement
des vacances et cela semble bien parti
pour le massif des vosges une
destination prisée avec des taux de
remplissage des hébergements ici à la
bresse pour cette première semaine déjà
de 80 %
voilà la montagne toujours les stations
de ski sont de plus en plus impacté par
le changement climatique et elle se
préoccupe de réduire leur empreinte
environnementale
pour y parvenir certaines d'entre elles
recyclent le caoutchouc utilisé dans
leur remontée mécanique vous allez le
voir celui ci peut être ensuite
exploitée et servir de revêtements les
explications avec ce reportage de
emmanuel jours pour la rédaction de 8
mont blanc sur place
la prise de conscience mondiale de
l'urgence climatique s'opère jusque dans
les stations de ski générant chaque
année près de 800 mille tonnes de co2
les domaines skiables français reste
toutefois à l'affût de solutions pour
réduire leur empreinte écologique
l'une les derniers en date concerne les
quelques 80 tonnes de caoutchouc
utilisés chaque année par les remontées
mécaniques sa caoutchouc il a une durée
de vie sain en caoutchouc la durée de
vie d'à peu près cinq ans et du coup au
bout de cinq ans on bat aujourd'hui ils
sont incinérés en fait et donc nous on
va les récupérer c'est caoutchouc on va
les amener jusqu'à la société plymouth
française donc à feyzin on a quoi
investit plus de 600000 euros là bas
pour
faire un outil de transformation du
caoutchouc on va revenir à de la pâte
prête à cuire on va dire et avec cette
pâte prête à cuire on va fabriquer des
sols en caoutchouc on évite à 80 en
france valait 1 brûlé et puis en
parallèle on fabrique des sols ici en
région auvergne rhône-alpes au lieu de
les rapporter l'asie l'investissement
permis par la région via le plan
montanier qui s'est avéré être payant
cela après trois années d'efforts et de
recherche afin d'élaborer un nouveau
procédé pour traiter tous les types de
caoutchouc utilisé sur le marché en fait
ce qu'on nous récupère on ne savons pas
du tout ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur donc
nous sommes obligés par la r&d de savoir
qu'est ce qui a comme additif des fois
vous trouvez du métal des fois vous
trouvé ta fibre d'autrefois outre vu de
kevlar mais on est arrivé à avoir
quasiment en stock chez nous pour ne pas
les incinérer 500 hommes medal
emboîtables ainsi créé composé de 75 %
de caoutchouc recyclé sont d'ailleurs
déjà installés dans les gares du fus ni
flaine tout fraîchement rénové pour
l'instant en phase de test le principe
séduit déjà de nombreuses stations
l'objective c d'ici 2030 bonsoir 0 m
carbone son attractivité le lier
son nom pendant que rien laissé de côté
suffit pas que ce produit soit issu
d'une filière de recyclage ça c'est très
bien il faut aussi qu'ils répondent à
nos exigences en termes de d'usure en
termes de résistance aux glissements si
les premiers retours sont positifs il
faudra toutefois attendre la fin de
saison et le vrai retour d'expérience
avant de proposer cette solution à de
nouvelles stations et à de nouvelles
nations
voilà elle vise aussi à améliorer notre
environnement les haines et faisons à
faibles émissions se multiplient un peu
partout en france à montpellier la zdf
sera effective le 1er juillet prochain
elle prévoit progressivement jusqu'en
2028 l'interdiction des véhicules les
plus polluants dans certaines zones de
l'agglomération montpelliéraine
elle inquiète aussi les entreprises
commerçants et artisans linsley wham o
pour vient occitanie sur place regardez
l'annnonce du calendrier de la z et feu
provoque l'effroi chez des
professionnels à montpellier la zone à
faible émission une décision
gouvernementale appliquée par les
métropoles prévoit l'interdiction des
véhicules polluants dans certaines zones
une annonce très mal vécu par ce jeune
artisan spécialisé dans le foot rock dès
l'année prochaine il ne pourra plus
circuler librement avec ce véhicule
diesel dans la ville noté critères cinq
véhicules pour nous il est essentiel on
le charge beaucoup ont préféré qu'on
fait aussi de la restauration donc lille
a un côté vachement pratique parce qu'il
est frigorifique un véhicule comme ça 9
bat ça vaut ça vaut ça vaut 50 mille
euros nous on n'a pas du tout les moyens
de se racheter un truc 9 antoine devra
pourtant se tourner vers l'achat d'un
véhicule essence moins polluants ou
électrique ces derniers impensable pour
lui problème du véhicule électrique
c'est que si vous lui mettez une tonne
et demie de charges à l'arrière
l'autonomie passe de 400 à 15 km voilà
j'ai monté ma boîte ya trois ans et demi
je joue le jeu à fond et j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya peu de
compréhension quand nous on demande un
petit peut être suite à l'annoncé du
calendrier la chambre des métiers et de
l'artisanat ont reçu plusieurs courriers
d'artisans inquiet j'ai plus de 300
artisans qui ont écris aujourd'hui ce
que je demande aux institutions c'est
collaborer complètement avec eux pour
pouvoir trouver une issue favorable à
tout le monde de l'autre côté la
métropole rappelle qu'il existe des
aides pour soutenir l'achat de nouveaux
véhicules et se dit ouverte à la
discussion nous allons être à venir des
dérogations mais sur les véhicules
utilitaires où il y a effectivement d
équivalence avec des modèles essence des
modèles au gaz naturel des modèles au
bioéthanol des modèles électriques là
effectivement les dérogations seront
plus limitative mais nous sommes
effectivement ouvert au dialogue une
réunion entre la chambre de l'artisanat
et la métropole est prévue le 18 février
prochain l'artisanat génère plus de cent
mille emplois dans l'hérault
et puis elisabeth bornes la ministre du
travail était l'invité de face aux
territoires ce jeudi sur tv5monde
elle est notamment revenu sur la
question de l'emploi des seniors dans le
cadre d'une réforme des retraites un
sujet qui pourrait être brûlant pour le
prochain président de la république
regardez à ce sujet cet extrait est la
réponse de la ministre
si jamais il devait y avoir un 2e mandat
d' emmanuel macron et une réforme des
retraites il ya quand même un sujet
c'est l'allongement de la durée de
travail alors que les seniors on le voit
ne sont pas forcément souhaité dans les
entreprises qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
là dessus alors vous avez raison si on a
effectivement et je suis convaincu qu'il
faut le faire une réforme des retraites
il faut s'occuper du maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors on l'a vu un même
pendant la crise un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui ont eu tendance à
proposer des préretraites à faire partir
les seniors je pense qu'on se prive
quand on fait ça de l'expérience de
salariés qui est quelque chose
d'extrêmement précieux pour les
entreprises donc c'est un jeu un dossier
à un sujet qu'il faut aborder en même
temps que la réforme des retraites ça
pose des questions de formation tout au
long de la vie on a de nombreux outils
pour se former tout au long de la vie
par exemple avec le cpf le compte
personnel de formation et puis il ya
aussi des enjeux des métiers dans
lesquels il ya une usure professionnelle
dont il ya de la prévention d'usure
professionnelle auquel il faut être
attentif donc c'est un volet qui est
tout à fait complémentaire d'une réforme
des retraites
le travail des seniors justement fait
l'objet d'une attention particulière à
limoges alors que le chômage a atteint
l'an dernier son plus bas niveau depuis
2012 certains restent encore sur le
carreau une discrimination est pointé du
doigt celles liées à l'âge à limoges
donc la boutique club emploi a lancé
généractions une initiative visant deux
tranches d'âge confronté à la méfiance
des recruteurs un reportage d'alain
druot sur place
quand on est en recherche d'emploi il
est reproché aux pas encore trentenaire
de manquer d'expérience et on bientôt
quinquagénaire est plus d'être dépasser
ces clichés s'accumulent et la boutique
club emploi a lancé une initiative
appelée généractions pour les moins de
31 et les plus de 45 ans mêlant travail
en groupe et individualisation de
l'action les faire se rencontrer ça va
permettre d'échanger un petit peu parce
que les moins de 31 ans et les plus de
45 ans ont parfois des ressentis et des
a priori de ce que pourrait penser les
employeurs sur leur manque d'expérience
les uns comme les autres vont se rendre
compte que on a tous des freins on a
tous des a priori et que par les changes
on peut enrichir de son réseau sa
manière de penser on peut avoir été chef
d'entreprise et utiliser les services de
boutiques club emploi pour y trouver des
conseils pour favoriser mon accès à
l'emploi j'ai une entreprise pendant un
quart de siècle et j'ai donc une large
expérience mais c'est moi qui
encadraient voilà totalement et
aujourd'hui je recharge pétain emplois
cette année onze sessions d'informations
sur le club emplois et générer actions
sont proposées au public
sur le fond de l'épidémie maintenant les
chiffres continuent de reculer en france
malgré une pression encore forte sur les
hôpitaux le pass vaccinale entrée en
vigueur il ya quinze jours sera
appliquée à partir du 7 mars notamment
en martinique au grand désarroi des
établissements relevant du public cinéma
restaurant salle de sport salle
d'exposition tous savent que la mesure
s'appliquera mais est-ce faire des
adaptations johan charpentier titi pour
la rédaction locale de via à tv
martinique sur place
couvre-feu passe sanitaires et
maintenant parce vaccinale une nouvelle
contrainte pour les établissements
recevant du public dans ce restaurant
l'optimisme n'est pas au rendez vous on
s'attend de toute façon à une diminution
de la fréquentation puisqu'on sait très
bien commenté nic les gens sont un peu
réticents à la vaccination
maintenant le pass vaccinale est composé
aussi du certificat de rétablissement
donc on espère non plus que que
la clientèle en tout cas restera fidèle
à notre offre mais ce n'est pas gagné
pour profiter d'un bon repas entre amis
il faudra se mettre en conformité avec
le pass d'ici le 7 mars sous peine de
devoir sacrifier une partie de sa vie
sociale une fois qu'on a ce sera en
place si on n'est pas vaccinée on ne
pourra pas sortir comme on le fait
maintenant parce que là on peut avec le
test je serai obligé de modifier mimi
loisirs parce qu'effectivement je ne
prie pas forcément ali ou de son
restaurant même cas de figure dans cette
salle de sport déjà éprouvée par deux
années de crise sanitaire puis
restrictions c'est un coup d'arrêt
supplémentaire chose dont le préfet déjà
au courant mais il s'obstine apparemment
à mettre tout cela en place malgré que
olivier vers en annonçant même temps sur
rmc que de passe d'accès passe vaccinale
ne durera pas avant
jusqu'à l'été donc nous on se pose la
question à savoir est ce que vraiment il
prend conscience de la difficulté
économique dans laquelle il met nos
entreprises et pour les adeptes de
musculation réfractaires à la
vaccination
il faudra s'adapter sont interdits
d'accès jeu va y aller j'ai pas envie
d'être la loi parfois ça si je veux
prendre le vaccin japon de moe vaccin
puis je retourne à la salle mai si je
n'ai pas envie je vais pas tourner la
loi je vais pas forcer l'accès de toutes
façons et mon métier de l'accès je vais
soulever des palettes cv d'emma moi je
vais débat puis ils seront peut-être
nombreux à emprunter cette voie pour
l'heure moins de 40% de la population
possède un schéma vaccinal complet en
martin voilà nous partons en gironde
maintenant sur le bassin d'arcachon où
les pêcheurs sont inquiets ils
protestent contre la réduction imposée
par l'europe de 37 % de leurs quotas de
pêche de sol un coup dur pour les
pêcheurs locaux qui peuvent néanmoins
compter sur le soutien de l'état la
ministre de la mère annick girardin a
notamment annoncé le déblocage d'une
enveloppe de 14 millions d'euros pour
renouveler les criées les pêcheurs quant
à eux pourront être indemnisés jusqu'à
85 % de la perte de leur chiffre
d'affaires des annonces détaillées lors
du déplacement de la ministre sur le
bassin d'arcachon réaction au micro de
la rédaction de tv 7 la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest en gironde tout le monde n'a
pas besoin de cet accompagnement donc on
va pas diviser la somme par le nombre
effectivement de crier et puis les
projets seront sélectionnés et ceux qui
en auront le plus besoin et c'est le cas
des criées touchés par les diminutions
de quotas de sole où nous serons aux
côtés de la criée d'arcachon comme
décrié qui sont touchées par la
diminution des quotas de sole je vous
disais dans les titres alors que
certains matin le thermomètre flirte
avec zéro degré à brest les bébés font
la sieste dehors oui vous avez bien
entendu dehors à la crèche jean de la
fontaine pionnière en la matière s'offre
au rajout pluies diluviennes l'équipe
propose la sieste nordique aux enfants
qui ont notamment des soucis de sommeil
et les bienfaits se font souvent
ressentir rapidement vous allez le voir
avec ce reportage de tébéo réalisé par
valérie leroux coléno sur place
c'est parti petit ourson voici or ces
deux mois et demi par et non pas pour la
balade mais pour le dodo un dodo ici en
plein air
dans ces petits lits à roulettes
résistant à l'humidité aménagé de
moustiquaires
ce matin là il fait 4 degrés les gouttes
de pluie ne sont pas très loin
quelques minutes auparavant je mets un
surpantalon sur elle parce qu'elle a un
pantalon
je rajoute des petites choses en voilà
sinon on allait convié pilotes qui sont
de différentes épaisseurs à part
quelques réveils pour cause de perte de
thé tea isaure dort beaucoup plus
longtemps balles et beaucoup en fait
dans les bras à la maison avec une
turbulette ça lui suffisait pas endormi
son est un petit peu plus compliqué du
coup on a essayé en dehors et ça a
marché ou pas elle se sentait je pense
plus en développer c'est que c'est ce
fut beaucoup dans les pays du nord et
donc ils sont plutôt réputé en termes
d'éducation je pense que ce soit en
terme de maladies de qualité du sommeil
très bien c'est en constatant il y a dix
ans que les enfants qui s'endormait lors
de la balade en poussette avait un
endormissement très serein et un sommeil
très réparateur que l'équipe nourrit le
projet les poussettes sont dans un
premier temps installé dehors fin 2018
cet espace dédié et aménagé il nous faut
quand même l'accord des parents et puis
après basions enfant qui décide on a
décidé en fête de pâques coucher les
enfants food zéro degré et surtout pas
au delà de 25 degrés c'est même plus les
températures chaudes qui sont gênés
d'autres enfants dans me dans cette
pièce intermédiaire la chambre ouverte
15 degrés au thermomètre
l'établissement pionnier est aujourd'hui
régulièrement sollicités pour partager
son expérience
l'idée la sieste en extérieur séduit de
plus en plus de crèches
voilà les puits si cette expérience pour
les bébés vous tente et bien vous pouvez
toujours d'attenté à l'âge adulte la
facilité de bien s'exprimer ou encore de
façon plus poétique le don de la belle
parole on en parle à présent dans ce
gîte et comme chaque année vous allez
voir le lycée europe de cholet organise
son concours d'éloquence le principe
invité les élèves à prendre la parole en
public et à travailler un thème bien
précis pour cette cinquième édition
c'est salomé qui a remporté ce concours
la lycéenne a axé son intervention sur
le thème des sorcières victimes
historiquement de préjugés des propos
recueillis au micro de pierre jeanneret
pour t elle c'est que voyez-vous quand
je vous évoque le mot essentielle mes
recherches m'ont permis de repenser à
son sens de ne plus penser à la sorcière
des comptes pour avant tout aux enfants
mais à la fin
on a eu des séances où les cdi nous
aider enfin les dames 10 et des pardons
il ya eu les parents donc j'ai pu
modifier mais mais bon je leur répétait
pas trop souvent parce que donc je lis
aussi je me suis je me suis entraîné
tout seul
voilà sans transition les plus jeunes
savent aussi se montrer généreux vous
allez le voir à monaco les étudiants du
lycée hôtelier ont entaché leur tablier
pour la bonne cause ils ont préparé un
repas gastronomique au profit des droits
de l'enfant pour réussir ce challenge et
satisfaire l'appétit des invités ils
pouvaient compter sur les bons conseils
du chef étoilé retirer des fourneaux
joël garault écouter le à ce propos
interrogé par alexandra pagny de monaco
un choix
les élèves ont vraiment été on va dire à
l'écouté des conseils que l'on peut
donner sur cet instant qu'on vient
partager avec eux et ça c'est quand même
assez extraordinaire
de sentir
on dit toujours les jeunes les jeunes
mais ils étaient très intéressés et ça
m'a fait plaisir de revenir un petit peu
où j'avais fait ses petites coupures et
vraiment ce de revenir et de regoûter à
ça c'est que du bonheur
maintenant départ pour l'occitanie avec
un saut au xvième siècle avec un tableau
datant de 15 120 qui a été vendue aux
enchères à la chapelle des carmélites à
toulouse ce tableau issu d'un retable
allemand très anciens a été découvert
dans un grenier toulousain à l'occasion
d'une succession estimées entre 600 et
800 mille euros l'oeuvre de bernard
stryges s'est finalement vendu à 2 8
millions d'euros l'acquéreur est un
musée restait inconnu image et réaction
par manon aussi de nos confrères de la
dépêche du midi sur place
incroyable il a dépassé vraiment toutes
nos espérances il était vraiment
magnifique on est extrêmement heureuse
que ce grand artiste et ce grand tableau
à l'appui
merritt en fait cette belle enchère on
pressentait qu'il allait dépasser un
million parce qu'il en avait eu beaucoup
de beaucoup de demandes de gens qui
étaient intéressés les acheteurs ont
vraiment marqué à quel point il a sa
place en histoire de l'art et ils
venaient de partout dans le monde
c'était à la fois des particuliers à la
fois des marchands à la fois des
institutions donc vraiment voilà tout le
monde de l'art s'y est intéressé
connu pour ses thermes et son casino la
ville d'enghien les bains et aussi pour
les arts numériques
jusqu'au 8 avril les visiteurs sont
invités à découvrir les coulisses du
cinéma de science-fiction au centre des
arts à travers l'exposition
interstellaire un voyage dans le temps
et dans l'espace avec elisa un état
devient 95 regarder
ce petit marsan n'est autre qu'une
maquette de pré-production du film mars
attacks réalisé par tim burton en
1996 cette miniature fait partie de la
nouvelle exposition temporaire du centre
des arts d'enghien les bains de cette
exposition s'appelle interstellaire et
s'organise autour d'un grand thème
spatial une sorte de voyage qui
interstellaire qui qui va faire
référence à un genre cinématographique
et qui est le space opera est qui qui va
retranscrire un petit peu toutes les
grandes épopées de son fiction
et de façon sous jacente aussi c'est
l'occasion de
parler de l'évolution des effets visuels
ou des effets spéciaux plutôt l'occasion
de s'immerger dans des films cultes
comme la guerre des étoiles avec une
réplique du droid c3po créé en
collaboration avec le musée du cinéma de
lyon interstellaire montre les
nombreuses étapes nécessaires à la
conception d'un film tel que la création
de prothèses faciales pour le long
métrage 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace les
histoires de jallet il faut bien qu'ils
comprennent que tous ces objets sont des
vrais objets qui ont servi sur les
tournages et donc ils ont ils vont
pouvoir déjà voir des objets qu'ils
connaissent par coeur ils vont pouvoir
les voir en vrai donc si on voir la
différence parce que faut pas oublier
que ces objets sont créés pour être
éclairé dans un film et non pas pour
être vu comme ça une plongée dans les
coulisses des films et séries de
science-fiction apprécié par ses
visiteurs j'ai vous appréciez les
costumes originaux et tout ce qui était
les dessins originaux j'ai beaucoup aimé
c'était vraiment une très bonne
expérience de pouvoir ça en vrai
commencer comment ça se
ça se construisait qui est vraiment un
sentiment d'originalité et
d'authenticité
on n'a pas l'occasion de voir des riez
quand on est au cinéma en fenêtre
ouverte du mardi au dimanche et gratuite
interstellaire est visible jusqu'au 8
avril prochain voilà nous ouvrons une
page cinéma dans ce journal mercredi est
sorti dans les salles les vedettes un
nouveau film du palmashow qui raconte
l'histoire de deux hommes à la recherche
de la reconnaissance publique via les
jeux télé le duo humoristique yvelinois
est venu présenter le film en avant
première à saint quentin en yvelines un
moment forcément hilarant auquel on
assiste et célia agathe son go et
grégory canal et de la rédaction de télé
on dit que vous chantez mais non je ce
genre était
[Applaudissements]
chanté les gens qui sont seuls si daniel
quel beau brun
ok tout le monde on a un champion on
regarde les caméras sur lui
c'est avec humour forcément qu'ils font
leur retour sur grand écran le duo du
palmashow signe les vedettes daniel et
stéphane son collègue tout les oppose
mais ils vont participer ensemble à un
jeu télévisé objectif gagner de l'argent
et surtout briller en société un film
sur le besoin de reconnaissance et une
critique de notre temps
aujourd'hui on a en cours après les like
sur les réseaux sociaux après les gemmes
donc on fait un petit peu n'importe quoi
parfois on se rend ridicule on a envie
de passer à la télé dans été arrêtés les
télé crochets courts après cette
reconnaissance est ce qui nous plaît
dans ce film c'était de raconter
justement une histoire d'amitié entre
deux types complètement en marge très
seul qui cherchent à s'intégrer de cette
manière mais qu'ils le font de façon
complètement ridicule mais qui par
chance vont se trouver passage obligé à
l'ugc ciné cité de skywest de montigny
le bretonneux pour l'avant première les
deux amis originaires de montfort
l'amaury on tourner une partie du film
au brevière parodier la télévision un
défi assez simple pour le palmashow on
essaie de prendre des des émissions qui
existe en tout cas des mécanismes qui
existent des mécaniques des missions et
après on y glisse un peu notre humour
différent un peu à chaque fois
on essaye de garder une forme de
sincérité on peut être malgré tout pour
avoir de l'empathie pour n'importe quel
personnage je sais pas si vous en avez
conscience mais vous avez un énorme
potentiel
suffisant les consciences reste six ans
après leur dernier film la folle
histoire de max et leon les vedettes
sortira dans les salles obscures ce
mercredi 9 février et en attendant le
palmashow a publié de nouveaux sketches
autour de la promotion du film sur l'art
chaîne youtube toute façon faut qu'on
s'occupe de la promo des vedettes là il
faut qu'on la deschiens avec lui sur
voiles déchirées c'est quoi la première
interview
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité on se retrouve pour
une prochaine édition aura tous
[Musique]